bonjour mes chers mes chers collègues
nous poursuivons et bonjour mesdames et
monsieur nous poursuivons cet après-midi
les travaux de notre commission
d'enquête par l'audition de Madame
Audrey dervelo présidente de sanofri
France je vous remercie madame la
Présidente de vous être mobilisés pour
cette audition vous êtes accompagnés de
Madame Clotilde Jolivet directrice des
relations publiques et gouvernementales
et Monsieur Jean-Marie Lacroix qui est
pharmacien responsable
c'est Jean-Marc
c'est marqué Jean-Marie
vous nous pardonnerez d'avoir écorché
votre prénom
Sanofi constitue un fleuron de l'indusif
de l'industrie française et plus encore
de son industrie pharmaceutique nous
avons pu très concrètement en avoir
confirmation sur le terrain jeudi
dernier dans votre usine de Lisieux qui
se consacre à la forme à la forme
fabrication du produit phare et le
doliprane antidouleur et antipéridique
préférée des Français je pense que
alors est-il préférée je sais pas en
tout cas
en tout cas le paracétamol est adoré des
Français nous avons été impressionnés
par le professionnalisme des équipes et
l'implication des personnels et donc
voilà vous transmet nous remerciements
pour pour cette visite qui illustre tous
les enjeux du secteur une demande qui
après avoir stagné pendant plusieurs
années crois à nouveau et des tensions
d'approvisionnement qui n'ont pas
empêché la production d'usine
d'atteindre un plus haut historique
à ce sujet un de nos interlocuteurs à
estimer que Sanofi par sa surface
financière était mieux armée que
d'autres laboratoires pour continuer à
s'approvisionner malgré les hausses de
coûts des matières premières et de
l'énergie
nous serons donc très attentifs à ce que
vous pourrez nous dire sur la façon dont
votre entreprise a subi et s'est adapté
autant aux tensions voire rupture
d'approvisionnement auxquels l'ensemble
du secteur fait face de manière de plus
en plus fréquente et notamment en
matière de principe actif plus
globalement nous déplorons tous qu'en
quelques années l'industrie
pharmaceutique française est perdu sa
position de leader en Europe et n'occupe
plus que la quatrième place sans en
faire porter la responsabilité sur un
acteur du marché en particulier bien
évidemment vous comprendrez que nous
souhaitions nous souhaiterions mieux
comprendre les sources de ce recul et
votre regard est important vous avez
évidemment un regard privilégié et vous
voudrez bien nous le faire partager pour
essayer de mettre fin à cette spirale de
déclin le gouvernement s'est engagé dans
une politique de relocalisation et
d'intensification du soutien à la
filière
vous nous direz comment sanofie a
répondu à cette volonté et mettra en
œuvre des projets s'inscrivant dans
cette trajectoire
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets madame
Présidente je vais vous céder la parole
pour un bref propos introductif tout le
monde est mis à la même enseigne c'est
bref
puis madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre mission de commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions comme vous l'aurez compris
notre commission d'enquête en temps
obtenir des réponses étayées à des
questions précises
mais je ne doute pas de la précision de
vos réponses je précise également que
cette audition est diffusée en direct
sur le site internet du Sénat et qu'elle
fera l'objet d'un compte-rendu qui sera
publié avant de vous donner la parole je
vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête est
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 430 4-15 du code pénal je vous
invite chacun à votre tour à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure madame dervelo
madame Jolivet monsieur Lacroix je vous
remercie et je vous laisse la parole
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je vous remercie de nous
donner l'occasion de nous exprimer sur
les tensions d'approvisionnement et les
pénuries sujets bien évidemment majeur
notamment après cet hiver où nous avons
subi une triple et inédite épidémie de
covid de grippe et de bronchiolite et
donc de façon plus générale c'est un
enjeu d'accès pour les patients à leur
traitement alors avec l'ensemble des
acteurs du système de santé nous devons
nous mettre en capacité d'anticiper et
de répondre à ses besoins de santé et
ainsi remplir notre mission de façon
plus optimale et cela compte éventuer
effectivement beaucoup pour moi en tant
que médecin et ont commencé ma carrière
dans les hôpitaux publics ce sont ses
besoins en santé qui guident nos choix
chez Sanofi et c'est notamment avec une
meilleure coordination des efforts des
pouvoirs publics des acteurs de la
production et de la distribution de
médicaments des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques des Logist
que la contribution au chiffre
d'affaires de notre groupe en France
plus que minime moins de 5% donc dans un
environnement économique contraint nous
souhaitons rester présent en France et
la France représente 40% de nos dépenses
de R&D et un tiers des investissements
mondiaux vous le voyez la France est
donc de loin notre premier pays de
production entre avec entre 30 et 40%
des volumes que nous produisons à
l'échelle mondiale donc plus de 10000
collaborateurs en France travaillent sur
ces affaires industrielles nous
investissons également chaque année en
France plus de 350 millions dans nos
usines avec une un investissement majeur
sur les nouvelles capacités et les
nouvelles technologies pour les nouveaux
produits avec 130 à 140 millions chaque
année en France
s'ajoutent à ceci bien évidemment des
efforts pour la décarbonation à hauteur
de 50 millions par an
donc la France a aussi été choisie par
notre groupe pour investir notamment
dans des usines de haute technologie
notamment dans le Rhône avec un demi
milliard d'euros d'investissements sur
notre nouvelle
usine high-tech de vaccin également le
site lyonnais avec une stratégie
d'accélération pour la RN messager sur
une avec toutes les étapes de la chaîne
de valeur à Marcy près de Lyon
par ses expertises technologiques
humaines et ses moyens financiers vous
voyez donc quelle place tient la France
dans la stratégie de Sanofi et je
voudrais encore une fois rappeler comme
vous l'avez dit que nos vingt mille
collaborateurs en France autour de 9
régions différentes sont une richesse
non seulement pour la France mais
rayonne au travers le monde nous sommes
contributeurs également de la balance
commerciale externe de la France Sanofi
exporte pour 15 milliards d'euros de
médicaments et de vaccins chaque année
concernant les tensions et les ruptures
vous l'avez cité et j'aimerais souligner
les spécificités du groupe nous sommes
un acteur unique en France puisque nous
avons plus de 464 présentations donc à
la fois un portefeuille innovant et un
portefeuille de produits mature
360 spécialités différentes
correspondent à 75% de MITM donc des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs et une vingtaine de vaccins ce
qui représente une
nombre de boîtes de façon très
conséquente puisqu'on a 460 millions de
boîtes dans les pharmacies de ville et
plus de 400 millions de prises en unité
à l'hôpital sur cette volumétrie nous
sommes évidemment malheureusement
impactés aussi par ces tensions et nous
avons donc eu 5,7% des 2765 signalements
à la NSM en 2022 à remettre dans un
contexte de notre part de marché donc
5,7% de signalement pour 18% du marché
en volume donc une proportion plutôt
plus faible contenu du volume du marché
français
conscient bien évidemment du besoin de
stockage supplémentaire et en accord
avec l'obligation de stock du décret de
mars 2021 nous avons également investi
en capacité supplémentaire de stockage
en plus de nos quatre sites de
distribution donc nous avons également
une capacité supplémentaire de 3000
palettes donc nous avons deux situations
différentes pour les patients des
tensions qui ne finalement n'empêche pas
le patient d'accéder à son traitement
donc le pharmacien pouvant proposer une
alternative en accord avec le médecin et
Sanofi peut également pratiquer lorsque
c'est nécessaire des réaors et une
deuxième situation plus évidemment
gênante pour le patient avec à la fois
des cadres rupture de stock par
l'exploitant ou des ruptures
d'approvisionnement liées à la chaîne
ces ruptures sont donc graves mais
d'imiter nous avons eu 157 signalements
en 2022 pour Sanofi dont un tiers
seulement pouvant aller jusqu'à la
rupture je souhaiterais revenir sur
l'exemple que vous avez cité ce qui a
été mis en place cet hiver pour le
doliprane nous avons répondu à des
besoins qui étaient très élevés
complètement inédit et de façon
imprévisible toute la mobilisation de
l'entreprise a été soulignée 424
millions de boîtes de doliprane en 2022
le plus haut niveau depuis son lancement
déjà en augmentation sur l'année 2021 on
nous étions à 383 millions de boîtes
pour la solution pédiatrique j'aimerais
souligner également que la production a
augmenté de 49% en 2022 par rapport à
2021 pour atteindre un niveau jamais
atteint de plus de 24 millions de boîtes
donc très forte accélération en fin
d'année nous avons comme vous l'avez
souligné sur le site de Lisieux en
Normandie des collaborateurs extrêmement
mobilisés qui sont passés à un rythme de
7 jours sur 7 24 sur 24 depuis quelques
mois et je tiens un souvenir encore une
fois c'est une réelle fierté pour notre
entreprise d'avoir pu contribuer à cet
effort
nous avons également mobiliser des
stocks en Italie pour venir aux besoins
supplémentaires pédiatriques à hauteur
de 4 millions
les causes je ne reviendrai pas sur les
causes citées lors des précédentes
auditions vous savez que principalement
avant la crise covid il y avait 20 à 30
% des pénuries du un approvisionnement
de principes actifs chez Sanofi nous
avons pris ce sujet depuis très
longtemps mais nous ne se sommes pas
finalement dépendants de la zone
asiatique puisque notre
approvisionnement en principe actif est
à 95% en Europe et aux États-Unis donc
5% seulement dépendant de l'Asie à ce
sujet nous sommes donc moins exposés à
cette dépendance avec seulement 15% de
nos tensions et rupture liées à un
problème de principe actif par ailleurs
les tensions et ruptures sont des causes
sont dus à des causes de multiples
factorielles et donc encore une fois je
ne reviens pas et surtout toute la liste
un point cependant nous avons été
particulièrement impactés par
l'augmentation imprévue de la demande
sur certains de nos produits et ce ne
concurrents créant un effet domino à
laquelle peut s'ajouter d'autres
événements bien évidemment industriels
imprévus sur la chaîne de fabrication
donc les difficultés industrielles
peuvent s'additionner avec aussi des
manques sur des contenants tels que le
verre la lumière les blisters les
sachets cartons ou des sucres de qualité
pharmaceutiques donc sur ces difficultés
d'intrants nous avons su trouver des
solutions grâce à la mobilisation des
équipes de façon exceptionnelle et
s'appuyant sur un réseau mondial très
fort à ce sujet je me permets d'attirer
votre attention sur le défi que
représente la disponibilité de la
ressource ultra spécialisée comme les
pharmaciens au sein de nos usines
indispensables pour la libération des
lots enfin je souhaite conclure par ces
propos avec quelques propositions nous
voyons trois leviers concrets le premier
levier et soutient aux deux autres nous
avons besoin d'une politique française
du médicaments en cohérence avec ses
objectifs de souveraineté et d'autonomie
permettant à la fois le financement des
médicaments nouveaux et innovants mais
également le financement des médicaments
existants pour les patients le second
porte sur les propositions du
gouvernement associées en amont les
industriels à la définition des plantes
préparation hivernales proposées par les
ministres de la santé de l'industrie qui
est une bonne approche car cette
anticipation avec les industriels ne
peut se faire qu'avec le pilotage de
l'État la définition des médicaments
stratégiques d'un point de vue
industriel et sanitaire M6 doit
absolument intégrer la soupe d'habilité
économique des productions à maintenir
mais aussi à prévoir et s'intégrer dans
les travaux équivalents au niveau de
l'Union européenne prévoir de mobiliser
la commande publique en cohérence avec
la souveraineté et nous pouvons si vous
le voulez vous donner un exemple sur
l'appel d'offres d'État sur les vaccins
de grippe
enfin le troisième levier serait pour
nous d'harmoniser au niveau européen les
conditionnements et les stocks en
conditionnement primaires pouvant être
mobilisés dans différents pays pour
répondre aux tensions
d'approvisionnement et de façon générale
que les outils instaurer le soi en
cohérence avec les travaux européens en
cours sur la souveraineté de l'Union
européenne je vous remercie pour votre
attention et je suis à votre disposition
pour répondre à vos questions
merci beaucoup
assez court et très dense
donc déjà il félicitations pour cette
performance
j'ai donc la passer la parole tout de
suite à Laurence Cohen notre rapporteur
oui merci beaucoup
madame pour votre propos introductif de
de synthèse vous l'avez vous l'avez
souligné les les difficultés
Valérie ruptures et les tensions sur les
médicaments on déco on va dire multi
factorielle et plusieurs médicaments de
Sanofi ont récemment connu des
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
France et je souhaiterais que vous nous
précisiez davantage là vous aurez un peu
plus de temps
lorsque un médicament qui est produit
par Sanofi se trouve en risque de
rupture ou en tension quelle mesure
concrète est-ce que vous mettez en place
pour pour y faire face
il y a une politique qui est menée en
France il y a eu depuis une trentaine
d'années donc des délocalisations
extrêmement importantes des usines de de
production
et on voit le résultat aujourd'hui c'est
pas nouveau il y a beaucoup de rapport
parlementaires et notamment du Sénat de
qualité qui avait mis en exergue c'est
ces tensions et ces ruptures qui n'ont
fait que croître et il y a plusieurs il
y a plusieurs raisons aussi qui ont été
qui ont été invoqués notamment par
exemple les questions de prix sur sur
les médicaments moi je voudrais vous
interroger à la lumière de ce qui s'est
passé pendant la crise du de la covid
est concernant notamment
le vaccin parce que c'est un lien avec
avec les questions que l'on peut on peut
se poser on a on a je crois tous et tout
était extrêmement déçus des appointés de
constater que Sanofi qui est un fleuron
de l'industrie pharmaceutique comme
laboratoire etc n'avaient pas pu sortir
un
médecin on est au pays de pasteur donc
bon ça nous a tout et tous beaucoup
touchés et aujourd'hui vous avez sorti
effectivement un vaccin d'ailleurs ces
trois ans après le début de la pandémie
et en fait il appartient c'est le 7e
vaccin européen qui a été approuvé par
les mains est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quels sont qu'elles sont qu'elles
en sont les raisons et finalement quelle
est l'utilité de sortir aujourd'hui un
septième vaccin par rapport au covid et
est-ce que vos difficultés on peut pas
dire qu'elles ont qu'elles étaient dues
par exemple à un manque de soutien
public puisque ce soutien public est
important à Sanofi et d'ailleurs
continuent à l'être mais je pense par
exemple au 200 millions d'euros d'aide
de l'État je pense au 120 millions du
cire donc c'est pas un manque de
liquidité si je puis dire
est-ce que c'est donc en lien avec
finalement les politiques que vous avez
menées en termes de fermeture de sites
de production vous avez cité des
chiffres mais il s'avère que je suis
dans le département du Val-de-Marne que
ça ne fit il y a une part importante y
compris dans ma ville à agentilly et je
m'en réjouis mais il y a eu beaucoup de
fermetures de sites alors est-ce que
c'est dû aux fermetures de sites et
notamment aussi à la pression qu'il a pu
y avoir sur les emplois sur les emplois
de production mais aussi sur les emplois
au niveau de la de la recherche donc ça
ce sont des prépositions qui me semble
aussi extrêmement extrêmement
importantes nous avons pu constater que
quand nous sommes allés à Lisieux
d'un échange franc et constructif et on
a pu effectivement un peu appréhendé ce
que vous avez mené au niveau de séquence
et de l'ouverture ce qui est très bien
d'une d'une usine mais le souci est
d'ailleurs ça a été souligné un peu hier
lors de notre de notre audition de
l'Académie de médecine notamment on voit
bien que la production de médicaments
comporte de nombreuses étapes qui sont
complexes avec beaucoup de
sous-traitance ça fragilise d'ailleurs
tout ça et du coup au niveau de séquence
ça va prendre en compte que les je crois
deux dernières étapes si je ne me trompe
pas donc je vous interroge sur oui c'est
bien les deux dernières étapes mais
est-ce que finalement ça va suffire ça
va consolider ça va faire en sorte que
nous ayons effectivement en France une
une production suffisante et surtout
surtout consolider quoi c'est ce que
c'est ce que l'on cherche on cherche à
avoir et d'autant que vous nous avez dit
que Sanofi
prenez en compte enfin s'approvisionner
plutôt en profit en produits actifs au
niveau d'à peu près 95% si j'ai bien
compris au niveau de l'Europe donc
ça c'est plutôt c'est plutôt positif
parce que nous tous les chiffres qu'on a
depuis le début de nos auditions c'est
de nous dire que 80% des principes
actifs j'ai dit produit mais c'est
plutôt principe principe actif était en
Chine et en Inde et là donc c'est un
contre-exemple et qui est tout à fait
tout à fait tout à fait positif donc moi
j'aimerais que vous nous donniez un peu
plus de précision d'autant que
effectivement vous avez pris une
décision au niveau du groupe sanofeed
vous séparez d'une partie de la
production en fait de ces principes
actifs va la session d'euro à pi que
nous allons d'ailleurs aller visiter
c'est une société donc et du coup
vous n'avez vous vous avez une part
minoritaire dans cette dans cette
entreprise donc est-ce que vous pouvez
vous pouvez nous dire comment ça va se
passer et vous êtes sous serment c'est
une commission d'enquête est-ce que
finalement alors que vous êtes minorité
vous allez pouvoir garantir que orohapi
d'ici quelques années ne va pas se
délocaliser en dehors de la France qui
serait effectivement grave pour pour
l'approvisionnement en termes de de
médicaments et puis une autre question
que j'aimerais vous poser c'est est-ce
que vous avez renoncé parce que là
encore au niveau de nos de nos auditions
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de remarques
sur les médicaments matures la faiblesse
des prix de ces médicaments matures et
qui sont eux frappés par par les
ruptures et les tensions est-ce que
sanofi a renoncé à mettre sur le marché
français
la fabrication de médicaments en raison
justement de prix trop faible puisque là
encore nous avons été alertés sur le
fait y compris quand des médicaments
étaient par exemple à abandonner et que
des petits labos voulaient bien les
reprendre c'était extrêmement compliqué
parce que effectivement il pouvait les
reprendre mais il n'avait pas alors je
vais peut-être l'exprimer maladroitement
mais les secrets de la c'est pas des
secrets mais les processus de
fabrication ce qui leur posait des
problèmes donc est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner des exemples concrets sur
ces questions voilà les la première
série de questions à laquelle je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez répondre
je vous remercie
beaucoup je vous remercie à vous de
répondre
et éventuellement
Laurence Cohen vous rappellera des
questions c'est certaines ont été omises
contenu de du nombre important de
questions
merci madame la Présidente je peux
commencer si vous acceptez je pense que
Monsieur Lacroix Jolivet
c'est pour ça qu'il a prêté ça merci
donc première question autour des
mesures
pour adresser ben ces sujets de tension
et de rupture donc comme je l'ai cité
rapidement nous avons une mobilisation
pleine et totale pour répondre à ces
situations on va dire d'urgence et donc
nous avons effectivement des allocations
on va dire de nos stocks de façon
classique et il y a des situations
d'urgence donc en ce qui concerne les
situations on va dire plus classique
c'est lié à des décisions de groupe et
donc étant la maison mère en France on a
cette capacité de pouvoir avoir une
vision aussi plus holistique et donc on
les stocks de façon générale en fonction
des besoins des pays quand une situation
de rupture ou arrive bien évidemment on
travaille là avec toutes les équipes qui
gèrent les stocks je vous ai dit on a
quatre centres de distribution on a une
équipe de 100 personnes qui est dédiée à
gérer aussi ces situations les services
clients les informations médicales et
donc on s'est mobilisé des équipes
supplémentaires pour gérer ces sujets et
d'arriver aussi à dialoguer avec les
autorités parce que c'est des situations
qu'on ne gère pas seul on le fait
vraiment main dans la main notamment
avec la NSM et donc je propose que
Jean-Marc que tu puisses se compléter
sur comment on contribue à gérer ces
situations spécifiques
madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames messieurs
avant de
nous repositionner dans le cas d'une
tension d'une rupture telle que vous
l'évoquiez madame la rapporteur en fait
il faut savoir que nous sommes organisés
tout au long de l'année et tous les
jours à procéder à une surveillance de
l'évolution de nos stocks sur nos
produits et évidemment particulier nos
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur
donc cette action de surveillance a pour
objectif de d'évaluer de déterminer s'il
y a des tendances éventuellement
anormales observées par rapport à nos
ventes et des phénomènes qui
seraient qui nous échapperait alors
comme l'a dit Madame dervallois
au-delà des personnes qui sont
mobilisées dans les centres de
distribution humaine donc sur la
manipulation physique des produits il y
a des plusieurs centaines de personnes
dans différents périmètres y compris en
logistique mais organisationnel en
qualité en informations médicales qui
sont en back office pour gérer ces
situations donc notre premier point
c'est la détection qui repose également
sur la veille des publications de
tension et ou rupture qui sont réalisées
sur le site de la NSM puisque c'est un
indicateur pour nous
d'éventuelles transferts de
d'achat sur nos propres produits donc ça
c'est une information publique que nous
exploitons
et puis nous avons des contacts
privilégiés avec différents acteurs
notamment les grossistes répartiteurs et
avec qui nous interagissons
régulièrement notamment pour
éventuellement obtenir l'état de leur
stock de leur propre stock et de leur
évolution et puis parfois avec
des centres hospitaliers ciblés en
fonction de certaines pathologies et de
leur spécialisation donc il faut savoir
que pour une entreprise comme la nôtre
qui a pour raison d'être de fournir à
chaque malade son traitement être en
situation de tension ou de rupture et
forcément une situation
d'inconfort voir des chèques par rapport
à notre mission
donc quand on détecte une telle
situation notre
première réaction et d'essayer d'estimer
au mieux le délai de survenu d'une
rupture réelle et dans communiquer les
informations à la NSM qui est notre
interlocuteur privilégié
dans ce contexte
évidemment notre objectif n'est pas
qu'un objectif d'information c'est aussi
un objectif de
contribution à la résolution d'une
situation qui n'est pas forcément avérée
mais qui peut être à ce stade seulement
un risque et c'est un point sur lequel
j'aurais peut-être l'occasion de revenir
c'est que et ça a été fait par la NSM on
voit le nombre de signalements réalisés
les signalements réalisés par une
entreprise exploitante ne signifie pas
une rupture de stock avéré
nécessairement au niveau y compris du
laboratoire
et notre objectif évidemment et d'éviter
cette rupture de stock par différents
moyens notre premier
objectif dans ce contexte et d'abord de
procéder à l'information de nos
interlocuteurs notamment des
dispensateurs que sont les pharmaciens
d'officiers ou pharmaciens hospitalier
par la voix d'un outil administré par le
Conseil de l'Ordre des pharmaciens qui
s'appelle le DP rupture donc qui est une
source d'information
ensuite nous informons
nous grossistes répartiteurs et nos
clients hospitaliers par des états de
stock
hebdomadaire pour leur donner une
visibilité sur la situation de nos
produits
au-delà de ça si la situation était plus
grave vous savez plus grave et ça
constitue également peut-être un point
sur lequel vous aurez l'occasion de
revenir qui est le plan de gestion de
pénurie que nous mettons en œuvre
c'est la relation avec les sociétés
savantes expertes dans certaines
pathologies qui pourront contribuer à
nous aider à déterminer le meilleur
protocole de remplacement éventuel ou
d'accompagnement des patients dans un
contexte de tension et ou de rupture
notre objectif étant conjointement avec
la NSM de ne pas arriver à la situation
de rupture complète au niveau du
laboratoire mais d'essayer de gérer un
stock contraint le mieux possible pour
qu'il bénéficie aux patients qui en aura
le plus besoin
donc ça passe par des contingentements
qu'on appelle quantitatif c'est-à-dire
une gestion à caractère purement
logistique et comptable si j'ose dire
c'est la répartition d'un stock
disponible sur un nombre de semaines à
risque donc organiser le cadencement des
livraisons de manière à prolonger la
durée de présence du produit sur le
marché le plus longtemps possible et
idéalement jusqu'au retour à la normale
des stocks au niveau du laboratoire et
puis dans certains cas la mise en place
de contingentement à caractère médical
c'est à dire que à l'intérieur des
indications quand elles sont multiples
et c'est fréquent pour certains de nos
produits de sélectionner des pathologies
qui exposent le plus au risque pour le
patient et de privilégier
le dépannage individuel c'est ce qui
évoquait madame dervelo à tout à l'heure
à une situation médicale précise donc ce
qui nécessite
l'implication de de personnes qui sont
plus orientées sur l'information
médicale que une capacité d'analyse
d'éléments médicaux évidemment anonyme
qui sont communiqués par le prescripteur
notamment à type d'exemple pour un
antibiotique c'est de se dire bah voilà
tel antibiotique va agir sur le microbe
concerné donc le dépannage est possible
alors pour les cas de contingentement
médicalisé oui ou via le ou via le
pharmacien hospitalier
d'officine ça peut arriver ça peut
arriver
la question au cas par cas absolument
donc vous discutez l'indication du
médecin
on vérifie l'égigibilité de l'indication
par rapport aux
discussions qu'on a pu avoir avec elle
un petit bout de temps mais je voulais
en avoir confirmation et je l'ai
désormais je vous remercie
voilà donc c'est un éventail de d'action
avec un stock contraint on est parfois
amené à
importer des produits donc soit le même
produit
que celui qui est disponible en France
donc qui pourrait être commercialisé par
une autre filiale du groupe dans un
autre pays dans la mesure où des stocks
pourraient être disponible voir de
d'importer des produits qui ne sont pas
de notre laboratoire pour supplier cette
situation voilà c'est un éventail très
large et ouvert qui est évidemment
validé et en concertation établi en
concertation avec les autorités
toutes ces points que ce soit du
contingentement quantitatif jusque à
l'importation des produits
donc la direction hospitalières ou la
NSM la NSM
vous donne mandat pour discuter au cas
par cas l'indication médicale avec le
médecin prescripteur pour vérifier
l'indication on ne discute pas
l'indication puisque c'est le
prescripteur qui est voilà
mon vocabulaire n'engage que moi mais je
dans les faits je sais comment les
choses se déroulent mais je voilà je
vous remercie
l'autre question
donc un sujet autour de la
délocalisation
avant de passer sur sur les vaccins et
je pense que vous l'avez compris en fait
dans mes premiers propos ça ne fit a
toujours fait le choix de rester en
France et de d'avoir tant sur la partie
production des API mais que la partie
production est distribution une très
forte présence en France donc c'est vrai
que nous on est vraiment sur on
maintient notre outil industrielle en
France je pense que les 16 sites par le
de même on est les seuls à avoir une
présence aussi forte sur le sol français
20 000 personnes en France et 40% de nos
investissements industriels en France et
on soutient aussi la production de
nouveaux médicaments à 150 millions
vraiment pour soutenir cette nouvelle
capacité alors je lis avant peut-être de
passer au vaccin mais je lis à votre
sujet sur la fermeture des sites puisque
en fait quel est finalement
de quoi on a besoin pour répondre aux
besoins des Français nous on gère notre
outil industriel en pensant à une
optimisation en fait du réseau
industriel donc il y a effectivement des
discussions de transfert de site c'est
vrai qu'il faut distinguer vente ou
fermeture d'un site d'un transfert parce
que quand on fait un transfert en fait
les capacités de production restent en
France donc on a effectivement des beaux
exemples en fait de transferts notamment
j'en ai un en tête avec Belfort ou le
site de Sanofi de Quétigny envers Dijon
a été transféré à delfarm et je pense
que tout le monde sait la robustesse des
sous-traitants donc c'est vrai qu'on
peut voir parfois ça comme une
fragilisation mais il y a des
sous-traitants qui sont extrêmement
robustes et français on a aussi le site
Merial qui a été transféré un
laboratoire allemand qui est très
présent en région lyonnaise on a aussi
on va revenir créer participer à la
création de roi API et on considère
qu'en fait ça renforce toute la chaîne
de production et d'avoir un champion de
l'API en Europe on considère qu'on
solidifie en fait pour nous la chaîne et
donc je pense que Clotilde va y revenir
donc vraiment on est sur une discussion
là aussi qui se fait avec les autorités
quand on veut transférer une activité et
donc encore une fois je distingue juste
transfert versus fermeture de sites et
c'est transfert ça nous donne aussi une
capacité d'investir j'aimerais mettre ce
sujet en parallèle puisqu'on a aussi du
coup sur cette même période et bien des
investissements qui sont absolument
gigantesques si on voit le site de
Neuville-sur-Saône c'est plus de 490
millions qui sont investis pour avoir
cette nouvelle
usine évolutive il y en aura deux dans
le monde une à Singapour et une en
France et donc on est très fier d'en
avoir une en France pour la nouvelle
production de vaccins qui sera vraiment
une nouvelle unité beaucoup plus agile
on a aussi un autre exemple
d'investissement à Sisteron où on
investit 60 millions pour pouvoir faire
des lancements de petits volumes donc un
autre exemple d'investissement et puis
aussi à Val-de-Reuil où on a 200
millions qui était investis pour la
grippe donc je cite ces exemples
d'investissement en parallèle puisque
forcément vous citez les fermetures mais
donc nous en parallèle on réinvestit
pour aller vraiment créer des nouveaux
centres d'excellence aussi en France
c'est notre volonté
[Musique]
ce qui est un sujet qui est lié
stratégique en termes de souveraineté
industrielle et sanitaire peuvent se
prendre la présence de l'État nous
paraît essentiel dans dans euro API
madame le rapporteur vous êtes également
revenu sur les sujets
relatifs à l'ennemi à disposition du
vaccin contre le covid de Sanofi qui
effectivement vous avez entièrement
raison arriver plus tard nous avons
bénéficié du soutien de la Commission
européenne qui est assez rapidement en
août 2020 a décidé de prendre des
décisions d'achat anticiper pour un
certain moment de vaccins dont celui de
Sanofi le retard que nous avons
enregistré était principalement pour des
raisons scientifiques pour un moment un
passage d'une phase 2 une phase 3 nous
avons dû recommencer des études de phase
2 et puis nous avons également un
recrutement des patients pendant la
phase 3 qui était beaucoup plus longs
que ce que nous avions espéré donc le
positionnement de ce vaccin il est
spécifique il a été discuté très en
amont dès que nous avons enregistré les
premières étapes de retard avec le
ministère de la Santé
et bien sûr la Commission européenne le
positionnement d'aujourd'hui de ce
vaccin est donc un position de rappel
c'est à dire effectivement il n'est pas
indiqué en primo-injection mais il est
présent pour le rappel ce qui fait qu'en
fait il est encore toute sa place
aujourd'hui dans l'arsenal thérapeutique
il a été évalué par la sagesse dans ce
sens donc voilà nous on considère que on
avait pris l'engagement de mettre ce
vaccin à disposition
sur pour le covid les délais n'ont pas
été satisfaisants mais l'engagement
était tenu et vous le savez c'est sous
bien sûr dans le cadre d'un
advance parchees agrement de la
Commission européenne et donc c'est un
contrat et donc nous avons vérifié
d'être en conformité totale avec avec ce
contrat peut-être un dernier point
là-dessus vous nous interrogez sur le le
lien finalement entre
nos investissements et peut-être
certaines baisses d'investissement en ce
qui concerne le vaccin il est clair que
la France est de loin la plaque numéro
un de notre activité nous avons trois
usines de vaccins en France plus la
nouvelle unités
à Neuville donc il est très clair qu'en
ce qui concerne le vaccin que ça soit au
niveau de la recherche et développement
et au niveau de la production de loin la
France c'est vraiment notre premier prix
d'investissement et de surtout les plans
c'est à dire la partie clinique
également nous avons des accords avec
plusieurs centres d'études cliniques
pour faire des études sur les vaccins en
France et avec la l'annonce de l'ARN
messager il y aura encore beaucoup plus
de perspectives donc il y a vraiment un
rôle très fort de la France en ce qui
concerne
les vaccins je termine avec peut-être un
point sur sur site
alors je ne serais pas capable de vous
dire exactement combien il y a d'étapes
de production dans dans le paracétamol
qui fait partie nous on a considéré que
c'était intéressant d'être partenaire de
ce projet parce que de toute façon ça
fait une partie de la chaîne de valeur
qui est européenneisée et ça ça sera
toujours toujours favorable nous avions
également noté que le quand silicone
savait présenter son projet il avait
quand même un volet décarbonation qui
était quand même extrêmement important
dans leur projet d'investissement qu'on
avait vu à l'époque ce qui était prévu
pour assurer une une production
décarbonée et respectueuse environnement
et un vrai plus par rapport à peut-être
d'autres productions qu'on peut voir
dans d'autres zones donc nous on reste
convaincus et c'est pour ça que nous
sommes partenaires de de du projet de
seekwins nous sommes convaincu que ça
répond à un des besoins d'avoir une
source complémentaire de de paracétamol
sur le territoire européen après le
nombre d'étapes effectivement je vous
avouerai je ne suis pas capable de me
prononcer sur ce point
oui je vais laisser la parole à mes
collègues mais j'aimerais avoir votre
votre analyse ou en tout cas votre
réponse plus exactement concernant
toujours euro happy parce que je
m'interroge beaucoup est-ce que
finalement vous avez bénéficié d'un
cabinet de conseil
pour décider de sortir
euroapie de Sanofi c'est très en vogue
et on est très sensible au niveau du
Sénat sur cette question donc si tel est
le cas
si tel est le cas et bien évidemment je
vous demanderai dans le cadre cette
commission d'enquête de nous communiquer
l'étude stratégique qui a présidé à un
tel un tel choix mais j'aimerais pouvoir
avoir votre réponse à ce sujet je vous
remercie oui je vous remercie madame le
rapporteur complètement transparente
avec vous je ne sais pas si on a eu
besoin d'un cabinet de conseil ce sont
nos départements de la direction
financière qui se sont occupés de ça
mais je ferai en sorte de vérifier qu'on
vous transmette les analysés les études
stratégiques qui ont été faites il est
clair que le on a vraiment étudié ce
positionnement de façon précise mais je
reviendrai avec plus de détails parce
que je n'ai pas les éléments
j'ai deux demandes de collègues est-ce
que d'autres voilà donc Emilienne
je pensais tout à l'heure tu m'avais
demandé c'est pour ça
je suis désolé
donc Laurence excuse-moi tu avais noté
merci Madame le Présidente
j'aimerais revenir sur sur des questions
de Madame la rapporteur et avoir des
réponses peut-être un petit peu plus un
petit peu plus fouillé vous avez parlé
de fermeture et vous avez justifié en
fait en disant c'est pas des fermetures
c'est des c'est des transferts des et
que vous avez beaucoup investi vous
revenez beaucoup sur les chiffres de
l'investissement
moi j'aimerais savoir quelle est la part
des financements publics dans ces
investissements
et
comment finalement la délocalisation
intra territoire français a pu jouer ou
pas vous parler de plutôt d'une option
de de rationalisation de votre outil
industriel vous l'avez souligné mais ce
qui est important c'est pas tellement
pas seulement d'aligner les millions en
termes d'investissement mais de voir la
contribution la contribution publique
d'aut
plus que l'implantation dans l'Hexagone
justifie des crédits aussi et qu'on
s'aperçoit quand on creuse un peu qu'en
fait c'est comme la souligner madame
leur rapporteur c'est qu'en fait c'est
les c'est les dernières phases de la
production qui sont concernées par cette
relocalisation et donc
alors quelle est la quelle est vraiment
la réalité de cette localisation et en
quoi peut-elle être une quelle
indicateurs on pourrait se donner pour
que ça soit une garantie de la de la de
la souveraineté sanitaire
après monsieur Lacroix vous avez vous
avez très très bien expliqué dans le
détail
finalement comment on gère la tension
sur la pénurie sinon la pénurie la
tension sur la pénurie ce qui nous
intéresse c'est en fait de ne pas avoir
de pénurie et d'aller vers la
souveraineté sanitaire alors que là on a
quand même l'impression que on est on
est sur une une gestion de la tension
mais on n'est pas sur une remise en
cause du du modèle pour ne pas avoir de
de pénurie or nous ce qu'on découvre en
tout cas moi ce que j'ai découvert dans
cette dans ce travail qu'on mène c'est
que finalement on a on a un modèle
économique qui est en train de se
bouleverser ou on a une partie un volet
qui correspond aux médicaments matures
qui
qui fait l'objet de pression sur les
prix et d'une vision de de rentabilité à
partir des prix et vous m'avez un petit
peu inquiété quand vous avez parlé de
d'exportation j'aimerais bien savoir si
des exportations sont des exportations
dans des pays qui rémunèrent mieux les
médicaments matures ou quitte à mettre
en cause notre propre notre propre
gestion de pénurie de quelle nature sont
ces sont ces exportations là ça serait
ça serait important de la voir et la
question de l'innovation parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que finalement dans le
deuxième volet qui est plutôt
la recherche et développement à partir
de l'arrivée des biotechnologies on voit
bien que l'arrivée des biotechnologies a
complètement transformé
l'industrie pharmaceutique et je signale
d'ailleurs une note qui vient de sortir
de la Fondation Jacques Delors qui
explique bien ce processus et donc qui
demande plus de moyens financiers de
savoir faire mais là on voit développer
finalement une innovation par des
startups donc c'est elle qui prennent le
risque avec un capitaliste qui vient pas
toujours de l'Europe et finalement les
Big Pharma
innovent beaucoup moins qu'elles n'ont
innové dans le passé et donc finalement
le chantage mais en tout cas l'équilibre
rechercher développement par rapport à
rémunération des des médicaments et
quelque part remis en cause donc
j'aimerais bien vous vous entendre
là-dessus avoir la transparence vous de
la manière dont vous alors le rôle des
cabinet conseil je reviens quand même
là-dessus mais vous avez vous êtes
engagé c'est très révélateur quand même
que vous me puissiez pas vous puissiez
pas répondre et j'arrête là parce que la
présidente me fait signe qu'il y a
d'autres intervenants et elle a tout à
fait raison
c'était une marque pas une question le
révélateur voilà
Laurence Müller Brown merci madame la
Présidente alors moi je reviendrai aussi
sur les les interventions de mes
collègues
la part donc dans vos investissements
des crédits accords aux médicaments
innovants par rapport aux médicaments
indispensables tombés dans le domaine
public est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner une idée du pourcentage
d'investissement dans vos projets dans
un avenir
moyen terme puisque on voit bien que les
ruptures sont en général sur les
médicaments matures comme vous les
appelez ça c'est une première question
ensuite je voulais revenir sur les
questions de Madame la rapporteur
concernant le vaccin en effet la
conclusion vous n'avez pas pu produire
un vaccin
pourtant alors moi j'ai des documents là
qui nous disent que vous aviez une
commande de vaccin selon les les
recommandations de la FDA et donc une
commande par le Département de la
Défense américaine qui vous a accordé un
milliard 8 de
voilà de budget pour produire un vaccin
adulte et pédiatrique alors le document
qui existe qui vous demande de fabriquer
ce vaccin il suit les recommandations de
la FDA la question c'est pourquoi pas
les recommandations de l'Emma
et liste tous les aspects techniques de
la fabrication jusqu'au prix final
d'achat par le ministère de la Défense
américain
les premières doses produites sont
réservées aux USA en priorité pour
protéger la population américaine c'est
à la page 30
toute publication des résultats doit
être validée par le Département de la
Défense américain page 31 et de
nombreuses pages sont noircis est-ce que
le gouvernement français pourrait
demander à avoir le contrat non caviaret
merci
[Musique]
qui parce que entre la théorie et la
réalité on a besoin de savoir et quel a
été la pare prise par les politiques de
régulation des dépenses de médicaments
dans la décision que vous avez eu de de
vous séparer d'une partie de la
production des principes actives il y a
la session de roapi donc on revient
toujours au même sujet mais c'est quand
même une question
et ma dernière question
concerne
finalement le la comment dire la
gouvernance des décisions en matière de
médicaments en France alors vous avez
l'expérience monde l'expérience
européenne l'expérience américaine voilà
et l'expérience française
qu'elle regarde vous portez cette sur
cette organisation il est souvent mis en
avant l'absence de pilote et est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est un élément
essentiel aux substantiel qui justifient
aussi qu'on a à faire face à une
aggravation drastique des pénuries
depuis une bonne quinzaine d'années je
vous remercie
donc Emilienne
parce que en faisant non je repense aux
problèmes où vous avez parlé de
transfert il se trouve que sur Toulouse
on a eu suppression d'une très grosse
unité de Sanofi c'était en 2012 2013 je
crois de mémoire et vous parlez de
transfert
mais j'allais dire dans votre R&D vous
avez aussi
fait un transfert entre guillemets dans
la mesure où il y avait une certaine
nombre de recherches sur le plan de la
chimie et il nous a été dit ici lors
d'une audition précédente que vous aviez
abandonné quasiment pour ne pas dire oui
quasiment la recherche en chimie et pour
vous diriger surtout sur la recherche en
thérapie génique ce qu'on peut
comprendre quand on voit le différentiel
de prix qui peut y avoir entre une boîte
de doliprane ou de Lovenox et puis une
thérapie génique à un million millions
d'euros le traitement on comprend qu'on
puisse choisir et donc vous avez quand
même à ce moment là sur sur Strasbourg
fermer
vous êtes séparés de quelques 400
450 je suis exactement
chercheur et
collaborateurs donc moi j'aimerais
savoir vraiment si le choix
industriel et de dire que l'on
axe tout sur les biotechnologies et le
donc en particulier donc tout ce qui
était rapide génique et que en abandonne
complètement
le la recherche en produit chimique et
je pense qu'il y a un domaine en
particulier alors effectivement il y a
vous produisez beaucoup de médicaments
matures et le problème du prix peut-être
effectivement
une question encore qu'on voit bien
qu'il y a des ruptures de stock dans des
pays où les prix des génériques sont
plus élevés que que
qu'en France mais c'est vrai que c'est
intéressant de savoir si votre choix est
vraiment de dire pardon si votre choix
est vraiment de dire que on abandonne la
chimie
et on se
cantonne allez je dire sur les thérapies
innovantes parce que effectivement les
prix ne sont pas les mêmes et la
transparence dans le domaine des prix
concernant l'innovation elle est
vraiment très très complexe on voit bien
le différentiel de prix entre
l'Inde et la France pour le même
médicament pour l'hépatite C donc c'est
pas uniquement le prix de la recherche
du développement etc qui est des
améliorations que ça apporte qui compte
dans le Prix voilà donc oui
madame la Présidente je commence par
certains sujets et puis Clotilde
complétera
le prix et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
parce qu'on est bien d'accord qu'on
préfère anticiper que que régler les
crises c'est clairement notre ambition
on voit en tout cas une certaine avancée
dans les discussions récentes qu'on peut
avoir avec les autorités et j'aimerais
quand même le souligner notamment autour
des discussions avec
la nouvelle liste qui serait M6 donc qui
incorpore quand même une dimension de
souveraineté aussi économique et on
espère que les industriels feront partie
de cette discussion autour des nouvelles
listes puisqu'on est bien conscient que
les MITM finalement représente une
grande partie de la pharmacopée et
vraiment pas tout c'est quelle liste
précisément donc la liste des M6 qui
sont en cours
il y a plein de listes il y a les
médicaments critiques c'est-à-dire un
risque de pénurie mais pour autant
essentiel donc c'est des MITM mais
vraiment dans situation de risque de
pénurie et donc là c'est une autre liste
que vous nous évoquez c'est juste pour
comprendre
alors il y a peut-être un point de
vocabulaire dans les échanges que nous
avons eu notamment avec le mystère de
l'industrie et la santé c'est les M6
donc c'est les médicaments stratégiques
d'intérêt alors il y a industriel
sanitaire je sais plus dans quel sens
c'est mais ça correspond à la définition
que vous venez nous donner madame la
Présidente si c'est exactement la mini
je peux pas vous le garantir mais c'est
vraiment ce travail qui a été fait en
entonnoir c'est-à-dire que le ministère
de la Santé a vu des sociétés savantes
et des prescripteurs pour identifier un
premier lot et puis peu à peu on
resserre en entonnoir sur ce qui a
besoin d'être sécurisé au niveau
industriel donc c'est probablement la
même sous vocabulaire qu'on a M6 avec
sanitaire et sanitaire bon il faudra
qu'on vérifie exactement le wording mais
c'est sans doute la même
donc merci donc déjà je pense que cette
liste mérite
d'exister et de revenir sur un point
important et on considère que c'est une
avancée ensuite il y a deux articles où
on aimerait vraiment voir des avancées
aussi c'est l'article 28 et l'article 65
l'article 28 qui ont l'espère permettra
en tout cas à tous les industriels
petits ou plus grands de voir une prise
en compte des coûts de l'inflation dans
la fixation des prix des médicaments
juste pour vous donner un exemple nous
sur la partie médecine générale sur 3
milliards de coûts de production on est
déjà en 2023 à plus de 300 millions
d'inflation donc plus 12% versus déjà
l'année d'avant on était déjà à plus
subi pour cent donc déjà je pense qu'au
niveau du prix on aimerait vraiment que
l'article 28 plus est appliqué et
devrait être une mesure en tout cas
aussi de redonner de l'oxygène à la
filière j'aimerais citer aussi l'article
65 qui devrait également
pour moi permettre d'anticiper ce type
de problème et devrait reconnaître aussi
la localisation française ou au moins
européenne donc on a vu des avancées sur
la partie de nouveau médicament mais
j'aimerais vraiment que ça soit aussi
sur les médicaments existants puisqu'on
considère que les besoins en santé des
patients c'est à la fois les produits
matures et les produits innovants donc
on attend en tout cas une désavancées
sur la partie des médicaments existants
donc l'article 65 est important
pour revenir sur cette liste de
médicaments on a mentionné des stocks
j'aimerais vraiment qu'on puisse et ce
que j'appelle des stocks qualitatifs
donc c'est que mon expression
personnelle mais ce que j'appelle
derrière stock qualitatif je pense qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à définir
collectivement quels sont justement le
type de molécules et de
spécialités qui devrait être priorisé
avec un prix en adéquation
pendant combien de semaines ou de mois
je pense que c'est un sujet qui est
aussi important et qui soit aussi
finalement en adéquation avec l'outil
industriel je pense que vous avez bien
compris que l'outil industriel ne peut
pas répondre en situation d'urgence à
toutes les situations
aussi prendre en compte la dimension
européenne l'idée c'est que les
médicaments ayopathion et si tous les
pays stockent les médicaments on n'est
pas sûr d'arriver à la finalité puisque
l'outil industrielle européen ne pourra
pas répondre à ça donc je pense qu'il y
a une histoire de d'être raisonnable et
responsable sur les stocks et c'est ce
que je me permets d'appeler du stock
qualitatif
et encore une fois on l'a pas abordé
mais je pense qu'il y a des discussions
à avoir en termes d'harmonisation
européenne et qui me paraît très
important de le dire aujourd'hui nous
souhaitons une convergence des
législations européennes donc sur cette
liste de médicaments prioritaires
critiques enfin on peut l'appeler
différemment sur les stocks sur les
conditionnements aussi est-ce qu'on
souhaite du conditionnement primaire
intermédiaire on n'a pas abordé la
notice électronique mais tout ce qui
peut fluidifier en fait
on va dire cette libre circulation des
médicaments et notamment en période de
crise est importante donc gérer au
maximum à l'échelle européenne nous
paraît aussi un moyen d'anticiper
ce type de situation
vous avez
énoncé une gouvernance
au niveau voilà différents
fonctionnements encore une fois nous
nous sommes pour une gouvernance
européenne et d'arriver à gérer ce type
de situation au niveau européen c'est en
tout cas ce qu'on souhaite nous en tant
que laboratoire français comme vous
l'avez vu avec une forte présence
française et européenne
et pour juste rebondir sur un point
spécifique qui a été mentionné sur
est-ce qu'on abandonne la chimie non
Sanofi n'abandonne pas la chimie je vous
ai cité l'exemple
oui mais après on est très présent on
vient de mettre 60 millions à Sisteron
sur justement un lancement de petits
volumes ce qui montre bien que les
patients ont besoin de la chimie je
pense qu'on voit dans notre portefeuille
je vous l'ai dit on a des effectivement
des médicaments innovants des vaccins
aussi innovants mais on a aussi encore
un portefeuille très important en chimie
tu veux peut-être rebondir sur les
autres oui peut-être en complément mais
en essayant d'être rapide
vous avez cité effectivement la
situation à Toulouse ou evothèque qui
est une très belle entreprise a repris
l'activité donc effectivement ça rejoint
un petit peu ce qu'on disait et c'est
sur sur les transferts on est très
attentif et c'est exactement exactement
aussi ce que nous avons voulu faire à
Strasbourg que quand nous même nous
avons des des décisions de ce type ça on
intègre vraiment la possibilité que des
acteurs
européens du territoire à leur novalix
qui a repris Strasbourg une belle
entreprise française et votait qu'un
acteur
de mémoire allemande mais très européen
donc une fois de plus il y a vraiment un
passage de relais qui est intégré dans
les prises de décision et qui fait que
les compétences continuent à son pas
sous notre bannière mais mais les
activités continuent effectivement le
les domaines dans lequel nous sommes
investis en termes de recherche on a
deux très belles molécules dans nos
portefeuilles aujourd'hui qui sont de la
chimie par contre effectivement il y a
certains pans d'activités de recherche
qui ne sont pas en France parce que
notre façon de
d'allouer par rapport à la stratégie de
Sanofi les domaines prioritaires se font
aussi beaucoup en fonction des
écosystèmes donc on va regarder je vous
citer tout à l'heure l'importance du
pôle vaccin vous le savez
l'infectiologie notamment en région
lyonnaise et mondialement connue nous
venons de d'investir pour le Paris sacré
cancer cluster parce que la connaissance
notamment à Gustave Roussy en oncologie
et aussi reconnu à l'échelle mondiale
donc il y a vraiment un lien entre nous
ce qu'on fait sur le territoire et cette
ce niveau académique le niveau
scientifique le niveau technologique
caché nos partenaires vous situiez des
startups et des biotech depuis plusieurs
années je dirais même depuis une plus
d'une scène d'années mais nous l'avons
accéléré avec la stratégie de
l'entreprise aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
faire Sanofi ne peut pas faire la
recherche sans l'apport des biotech
parce que ils ont effectivement des
savoirs extrêmement complémentaires si
je peux un petit peu simplifier nous on
va apporter beaucoup à une biotech notre
capacité à faire de l'étude clinique
pour une biotech faire une grande étude
clinique avec beaucoup de patience et
d'une complexité absolue sont des
investissements majeurs et c'est souvent
là qu'il y a des partenariats en tout
cas on fait ce qu'on appelle de
l'innovation ouverte on travaille
beaucoup avec l'Académie qu'on travaille
beaucoup avec le CEA un travail le CNRS
avec l'INSERM on travaille avec des
biotech chacun dans la chaîne de valeur
à quelque chose à apporter donc et c'est
un mouvement qu'on observe il y a
vraiment l'innovation ouverte depuis
plusieurs années mais c'est vraiment
comme ça nous qu'on fonctionne en
fonction du vrai savoir-faire qui a sur
le territoire j'ai testé l'oncologie les
vaccins mais il y en a d'autres et puis
comme ça effectivement des pépites aussi
il y a des très belles biotechs des
petites boîtes qui font une toute petite
partie de la science mais qui est
excellente donc on va chercher cet
excellence
voilà par rapport au biotech vous nous
interrogez aussi alors on avait des
compléments d'information vous donnez
sur sur Euro API très rapidement sur le
covid et le vaccin donc le vaccin est
disponible il est disponible en officine
en vaccin de rappel vous avez cité le
contrat américain qui est un contrat le
contrat avec la barda qui effectivement
s'occupait du volley américain en ce qui
nous concerne sur la sur la France le
contrat de référence et le contrat de la
Commission européenne qui est de nature
différente la barda américaine a plutôt
des logiques de contrats de financement
de recherche et développement la partie
européenne était une logique d'achat
anticipée c'est des logiques
complémentaires et vous savez qui
aujourd'hui l'agent serra ça rejoint
sans doute les sujets gouvernance dont
on parlait on est convaincu que l'agence
ERA dans les sujets de souveraineté
sanitaire et industrielle de l'Europe a
vraiment un rôle à vraiment un rôle à
jouer
alors voilà déjà pour des premiers
éléments de réponse
alors
je serai j'aurais vraiment du mal à vous
répondre en part et en pourcentage ce
que je peux vous citer c'est
qu'effectivement nous avons pu avoir des
aides de France relance
au moment de la mise en place de France
relance le secteur de la santé a été
extrêmement important
beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle nous des
CDMO donc des sous-traitants ont été
soutenus par France relance parce que il
y a eu une identification d'un besoin de
beaucoup de production notamment de mise
en flacon qui a été très accélérée donc
Sanofi dans ce mouvement a fait
effectivement partie d'une allocation de
France relance c'était pour notre site
d'Aramon
je vous donnerai les ordres de grandeur
on a également deux types de financement
on a eu des financements de l'ADEME pour
un projet de décarbonation et nous avons
également eu
aide régionale vous savez que les FEDER
ont rejoint l'étudios européens l'effet
d'air également sont bénéficiés à
certains projets d'investissement de
Sanofi je vous remercie c'était pas
vraiment ma question il y a pas il y a
pas de pénurie de financement public
c'était la part dans vos projets
d'investissement dans les médicaments
matures et d'investissement dans dans
les dans les médicaments innovants
c'était votre vous votre budget à vous
comment l'avez-vous envisagé pour nous
donner une idée de là où vous allez
investir en pourcentage d'accord pardon
merci alors effectivement sur nos
investissements à nous on a
sur si je prends les exemples de l'année
2022 nous avons 350 millions d'euros
d'investissement industriels et merci et
sur la partie vraiment nouvelle capacité
c'est à dire des nouveaux volumes on
était effectivement à plus de 200
millions sur l'année 2022 on pourra vous
redonner des absolument plus détaillé on
les a mis dans le questionnaire qu'on a
envoyé en amont de cette audition donc
oui la part des nouvelles capacités
importantes de nos investissements
surtout depuis trois quatre cinq ans
voilà vous voyez sur une année c'est 200
millions sur 380 et vous avez le tableau
détaillé dans dans le questionnaire et
si je peux rebondir c'est pas exactement
votre question mais pour donner une
ampleur sur l'investissement en R&D de
la recherche c'est-à-dire que les
investissements publics pour le secteur
pour le secteur dans R&D c'est à peu
près 1% si on met excepté les crédits
impôts recherche 1% excepté le crédit
pour recherche donc l'investissement
privé aurait été important et donc pour
Sanofi c'est 2 milliards oui pour
revenir sur la
l'énergie mais pour la partie R&D de
Sanofi en France et demi à donc on est
le premier investisseur on fera privé en
R&D je pense que c'est important de
souligner de toute façon ça va ça fera
partie du questionnaire écrit qu'on vous
fera intervenir vous n'avez pas répondu
à la question de est-ce que est-ce que
il y a eu un renoncement à mettre sur le
marché français ou abandonné la
fabrication de médicaments destinés à
notre au marché de notre de notre pays
en raison des prix trop faibles cette
question du prix des médicaments c'est
non singulièrement vous l'évoquez peu
alors qu'en fait ça a été beaucoup
essayé le même l'a beaucoup évoqué
répartition des rôles on est
complètement en aligné avec la position
du LEM donc ce qui a été dit par le LEM
on le soutient pleinement donc je vais
pas répéter ce qu'ils ont dit en
revanche pour répondre à votre question
pour ça pour connaître la réalité des
choses non à ce jour je rajouterais
qu'on est extrêmement inquiet par la
situation et comme le l'aime on
souhaiterait c'est pour ça que je me
permettais de rappeler l'article 28
l'article 65 qui doivent être en place
mais donc pas à ce jour mais évidemment
on est très inquiet par la situation
actuelle donc pour être précis vous avez
le sentiment que sur un certain nombre
de médicaments matures vous êtes arrivés
vous êtes arrivés à un prix tellement
bas que vous n'êtes plus en situation de
garantir sa présence c'est c'est pas
dans des conditions favorables
exactement
c'est répondu avec diplomatie
pour avoir des réponses quand même un
peu un petit peu plus précise plusieurs
de mes collègues vous ont interrogé sur
finalement
des un peu l'avenir et la chimie
pharmaceutique on va dire de demain or
vous avez un site normalement qui est
emblématique de cette de cette chimie
pharmaceutique de demain je pense aussi
de cisteron or le bâtiment où sanofi a
investi à ma connaissance mais vous
allez où me conforter ou me détromper
n'a pas l'activité escomptée par manque
justement de molécules alors est-ce que
c'est réel ou pas ça c'est ma première
question deuxième question sur le R&D
le versement des dividendes de sanofioc
représente plus de 50% de ses bénéfices
soit 4,1 milliard d'euros est-ce que
c'est compatible avec avec une politique
de recherche ambitieuse et combien de
salariés sont associés aux activités de
recherche alors que les personnels du
groupe ont diminué de 28% de 2007 à 2023
c'est une question précise qui demande
des réponses précises parce que nous
sommes sur une commission d'enquête je
vous remercie
beaucoup ça sera les dernières questions
alors je réponds pour l'instant sur les
dividendes et donc je regarde c'est mes
collègues dans la réponse se précise ou
pas sur sister
les dividendes qui sont versés donc sont
évidemment déjà une source de robustesse
financières du groupe et donc bien
évidemment d'avoir un leader Français
qui est en situation
financière solide et déjà je pense une
source de satisfaction et je tenais à le
dire aujourd'hui les dividendes qui sont
verts ne remettent pas en question les
arbitrages qui pourraient y avoir sur la
R&D ou sur l'investissement industriel
donc ça c'est important juste pour
donner un ordre de grandeur je vous
disais 2 milliards d'investissements R&D
en France c'est 6 milliards pour le
groupe c'est une 9 milliards qui sont
sur la masse je vous donne les chiffres
de 2021 9 milliards qui sont investis
typiquement sur les salaires c'est 14
milliards qui sont investis sur les
achats fournisseurs donc juste pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur et en tout
cas il y a pas d'arbitrage aujourd'hui
qui mettrait en péril des
investissements industriels ou R&D et
pour dire aussi qu'un certain nombre de
collaborateurs aussi touche une partie
puisqu'on a des collaborateurs qui sont
actionnaires sur la partie nombre de
collaborateurs qui travaillent à la fois
en R&D et à faire industrielle on a
aujourd'hui 4000 personnes qui
travaillent sur la R&D en France et
11000 personnes qui travaillent sur
l'outil industriel dans ce qu'on appelle
à faire industrielle donc on a
finalement 15000 collaborateurs c'est la
majeure partie de nos collaborateurs sur
le sol français donc
les 5000 mots sur les sites donc on a
après toutes les autres fonctions les
logistiques etc on a les sites
tertiaires on a aussi les fonctions
globales le site enfin pardon la France
et le site vers la maison mère donc on a
aussi toutes les fonctions pour le
groupe mais donc la majorité à faire
industrielle 4000 de R&D
alors plus spécifiquement sur ces tirons
faudra qu'on vérifie l'information il
peut il peut effectivement y avoir un
bâtiment qui est en moindre activité que
de d'autres mais j'ai pas l'information
là en tête par contre effectivement
c'est un site sur lequel on a investi
notamment pour cette nouvelle unité de
lancement donc on vient faire plus
précisément mais c'est un site qui a
bénéficier d'investissement notamment
cette unité de lancement c'est 60
millions sur plusieurs années on est
vraiment convaincu que il y a la
capacité des compétences là-bas pour
pour faire des belles choses c'était des
produits en chimie de notre
issue de notre recherche et
développement ou nos collaborations donc
il y a vraiment un potentiel mais je
ferai vérifier j'ai des informations sur
Sisteron donc on a 600 collaborateurs
sur le site de Sisteron 120 R&D
480 en affaires industrielle donc et
produit aujourd'hui
le tolé brutini qui est donc un
médicament développement dans la
choses en plaques on a 25 millions
d'euros qui ont été investis en 2021
donc à part des 60 millions qui étaient
lycées et les principaux projets donc
c'est effectivement suite des lancements
petits volumes mais on est aussi un
développement de procédés chimiques
continuent par micro fluide tel quel je
suis pas forcément une experte du sujet
simplement mais là ça fera l'objet d'une
réponse précise au niveau du
questionnaire qu'on va vous envoyer
pourquoi pourquoi ma question parce que
il y a eu plusieurs sites de Sanofi où
il y a eu des investissements
extrêmement importants dans des
bâtiments et finalement ensuite il y a
eu abandon donc il y a eu quelques
millions qui ont été investis
et finalement avec un changement ensuite
de politique donc j'aimerais savoir si
au niveau de cistéran c'est la même
chose ou pas et donc c'est pour ça que
les questions sont assez pointues je
vous remercie
un grand merci Madame ma directrice
est-ce que vous souhaitez apporter des
éléments complémentaires qui vous
viennent à l'esprit avant la fin de
cette audition
non vous remercier pour votre écoute
merci beaucoup
c'est un échange voilà un bateau rompu
un peu solide on va dire les choses
comme cela mais c'est l'objet de cette
commission d'enquête et comme les
pénuries sont pas un phénomène tout à
fait nouveau et que la gravation est
plutôt très exponentielle on a aussi à
cœur
de déboucher sur des propositions
qui vont être comment dire rapidement
efficace voilà pour pouvoir
rattraper le temps perdu
je vous remercie beaucoup au revoir
et donc nous nous retrouvons à 17h pour
les représentants de la distribution
pharmaceutique